loves working here in the cafe that her
family runs flat white
they originally came from Iran Nika says
when it comes to finding stuff it's hard
to find British workers who'll stick
around so foreigners are vital the
majority at the moment are from Canada
or Australia we've got Portuguese
Spanish people I think we should be
encouraging people to come because
obviously the more money that they earn
the more tax that they pay and all in
all it goes into the economy anyways so
I think it's good it's a good thing you
need more immigrants the need for
foreign labor is clear in many parts of
Britain not just in Hospitality but
areas like education and Healthcare and
it partly explains the jump in net
migration last year to a headline figure
of 606 000 compared to 488 000 in 2021
we know some of the factors behind the
net migration figure firstly
work-related visas for non-eu Nationals
accounted for an estimated 137
000 arrivals in 2021 that Rose to 235
000 last year many took jobs in sectors
where there are big staff shortages such
as Health and Social care secondly there
were 301 000 study related visas in 2021
that jumped to 361
000 last year most of the rise was down
to more family members coming over two
years ago humanitarian visas accounted
for 57 000 arrivals this more than
trebled to 172 000 last year mainly due
to Ukrainian and Hong Kong Nationals and
in 2021 about 53 000 people claimed
asylum in the UK that Rose to about 76
000 last year
but the government insists it'll bring
down net migration to relieve pressures
on housing and public services this week
it announced new rules barring most
overseas students from bringing
dependents with them I want to bring the
numbers down the measures we've
announced this week are more impactful
than anything that anyone has ever
announced before when it comes to
tackling migration and it goes alongside
our other plan though to stop the boats
because that's really important of
course the numbers reaching the UK by
irregular routes like those Crossing
from France in small boats most of whom
eventually claim Asylum are dwarfed by
overall immigration and one right of
Center Think Tank accuses the government
of throwing red meat to disaffected
voters rather than addressing the needs
of the economy the way in which the
economy is currently shaping given the
recession we have just narrowly avoided
given the high rates of inflation we're
seeing and given that we're losing a lot
of EU migration following brexit I
really don't see how the government
could really bring down those numbers
and keep the economy at a stable level
where it's aiming for growth the
opposition labor party says the rise in
net migration shows the government's got
no plan and says it would bring numbers
down through training programs but
beyond the pledges lies a challenge how
to square the circle of cutting
immigration while avoiding more damage
to vital Services Nadeem Barber Al
Jazeera London